Nancy Pelosi is sworn in as the new
Speaker of the House the far left makes
its policy pitch and the shutdown
continues this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man so much to get to today all the
Democrats had to do was not be bat bleep
Looney that's all they had to do and
they just couldn't do it the first day
of the new Democrat Congress goes about
as horribly as you'd expect and the new
economic report out that shows that
president Trump's economy is not slowing
down not quite yet we'll talk about all
of that in just a second first let's
talk about how you make your home and
neighborhood safer today over a million
people use the amazing ring video
doorbell to help protect their homes I
know that we do at my house we are very
concerned about safety not only because
I'm a public figure but also because I
have young kids ring video doorbell
allows me to see who is ringing my
doorbell anytime day or night no matter
where I am in the country it rings
directly to my phone I can answer it I
can call the police I can do all sorts
of things to make sure that my home is
safe a lot of people try to ring the
doorbell to see if you're home before
they rob your house well they're not
gonna know if you're home with ring
video doorbell ring nose home security
begins at the front door but it does not
end there so right now they're extending
that same level of security to the rest
of your home with the with the ring
floodlight cam just like the ring
amazing doorbell floodlight comes a
motion-activated camera and flood led
the connects right to your phone with HD
video two-way audio it lets you know the
moment anyone steps on your property
ring floodlight offers the ultimate in
in home security with high visibility
flood lights a powerful HD camera that
put security in your hands with ring you
are always at home save up to one
hundred and fifty bucks off that ring of
security kit when you go to ring.com
slash Bend again that's ring.com slash
been once more ring calm slash man go
check it out
ring products are great and they do help
you keep your home safe and make you
feel more secure ring calm slash Ben go
check it out ok so day one of the New
Democratic Congress all the Democrats
are sworn in and it's a beginning of a
new dawn I mean look at how the media
portrayed this it was fresh faces galore
diversity beautiful diversity diversity
of the radical left because it turns out
that all the Democrats had to do when
they took office was not be completely
insane and they just couldn't do it it's
truly amazing if you look back at the
last days of the 2018 campaign the key
question in the 2018 campaign was going
to be who were voters going to focus on
were they going to focus on the foibles
of the Republicans or they going to
focus on the myriad stupidities of the
Democrats in the aftermath of the judge
Cavanaugh hearings where Democrats
proved themselves to care nothing about
due process or decency Republicans sky
rocketed in the polls because all the
focus was on how terrible the Democrats
were and then President Trump shifted
the topic from judge Kavanagh to the
caravan and to his border policies and
suddenly the focus was on Republicans
and people decided they didn't like the
Republicans and they ran screaming from
the Republicans and Republicans ended up
losing the popular vote in the House by
eight point six percentage points the
same thing happened in 2016 the question
was is the focus on Hillary or is the
focus on Trump when the focus was on
Trump Trump went down in the polls when
the focus was on Hillary as it was at
the very end of the election in large
part thanks to James commis memo at that
point the focus shifted to Hillary
Clinton and Hillary Clinton lost well in
whoever the focus is on is going to lose
because it turns out that Americans hate
both parties Americans think that both
parties stink Americans hate these
politicians and so whoever they are
focused on at that moment whoever the
public eye of Sauron elect upon is going
to be in trouble so all the Democrats
had to do for 2020 was just keep the
focus on President Trump they can't do
it because they're crazy and it turns
out that their agenda is radically to
the left radical left they're not
bringing up any serious policy proposals
they're not bringing up any serious any
serious measures to alleviate the
problems that America is experiencing
they're not unifying Americans around
common values or decency instead they're
going to be just as crazy as they can be
and the media are going to celebrate
them for it the media are going to talk
about how wonderful they are for being
incredibly radical so Nancy Pelosi takes
the gavel yesterday as Speaker of the
House after 8 long years in the
wilderness she is back and her first
thing is that she says that she's going
to tackle climate change ok if we are
going to actually look at the priorities
that Americans care about climate change
is not in the top 10 climate change is
not a major priority for Americans
specifically because if you look at the
statistics America's carbon emissions
have actually been dropping in recent
years ok the statistics show that two of
the chief ways visit noah rothman rights
that's a commentary today two of the
chief ways in which individuals can
reduce their carbon footprints according
to the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change that's the UN would be to
purchase electric or hybrid cars or to
install smart thermostats in their homes
and consumers are already doing that in
the United States where you got that
nest thermostat that the state pays for
people are putting that in there
House already also us carbon emissions
declined to a 67 year low in 2017 the US
power generation sector cut emissions by
28% since 2005 the u.s. is meeting its
Paris climate Accord targets despite
having left the stupid agreements in
early 2017 right all that's happening
and Americans are not deeply concerned
about climate change because they do
recognize that in reality technical
technological change is going to outpace
all the sort of socialistic cram downs
that Democrats want nonetheless Nancy
Pelosi targets climate change as her
chief priority and she's not the only
one Bernie Sanders was saying climate
change is the top priority Hank Johnson
was saying the climate change is a top
priority Democrats across the board are
saying climate change is their top
priority
that's where you're going really to
climate well here's Nancy Pelosi doing
it yesterday the extension threat of our
time the climate crisis a crisis
manifested in natural disasters of epic
proportions the American people
understand the urgency the people are
ahead of the Congress the Congress must
join them and that is why we have
created a Select Committee on climate
crisis the entire Congress must work to
put an end to the inaction and denial of
science that threaten the planet and the
future okay if you really think that
this is what the American people are
looking for you're out of your mind
and the Democrats campaigning on this is
crazy it's particularly crazy when you
have people like Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
who's thrown out what she calls a green
New Deal a her green New Deal document
that you put out yesterday is fully
crazy it's the text of a proposed house
rule change outlining a plan her green
New Deal now the reason that we bring up
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez this is always
what I want to out with we're not
bringing her up because we think she's
an inherently important person okay
she's a woman who won 12,000 votes in a
heavy Democrat district in a primary
that was majority minority and had a
white representative and they threw him
out in favor of Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
this was not some sort of great puzzle
this is not some sort of massive
movement inside the American public but
she has been touted by the media as a
leader in the Democratic Party it's not
my fault that the media decided to
choose a complete ignoramus as the face
of the new Democratic Party is not my
fault that's the fault of the Democrats
and the fault of the media and that
means that is now incumbent on us to
take whatever crazy ideas she has
seriously now listen I'll admit that
Alexander Ocasio Cortez is a good dancer
there's this video that came out of her
yesterday dancing on top of a rooftop
and for some reason I guess there were
people there wasn't anybody on the right
that I saw who's upset about this we all
thought oh this is kind of charming and
fun there was one person on Twitter who
said this just shows Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez is privileged or something and
everybody came down on this person so
hard that they actually left Twitter the
media played it as though conservatives
were scolding her over her dancing I
don't care that she's dancing she seems
like a pretty good dancer I mean here's
the video of her dancing on a rooftop
basically re-enacting one of the kind of
montages from The Breakfast Club it's
cute and it's funny it's nice I mean who
cares like we can show it here she has
dancing dancing around right cute girl
dancing around alright well it turns out
she is significantly significantly
better at dancing than she is at
economics now if you asked me to take
her seriously as a dancer I'd be like
okay this video is important but this
video isn't important okay the part
that's important is that she doesn't
know anything about economics and she
says crazy crap all the time and that's
what the New Democratic Party is what
they want you to see is the fun girl
dancing and being Alyx from the Bronx or
whatever she calls herself what she
actually is is a crazy loon bag
socialist who's a member of the
Democratic socialists of America and now
here are the details of her green New
Deal that she put out hey this is nuts
here's what she says is according to Tom
Elliot over at gray bein calm the
proposed rule change for the upcoming
116th Congress would require the
creation of a select committee for a
Green Deal
that would be responsible for creating a
plan by January 1st 2020 with
corresponding draft legislation
soon after the text of the rule change
lays out the committee's jurisdiction
and required areas of action its scope
and mandate for legislative authority
amounts to a radical grant of power to
Washington over Americans lives homes
businesses travel banking and more so
what exactly are they looking for what
is she looking for their goal is to meet
100% of national power demand through
renewable through renewable sources okay
by like twenty twenty or by 2030 then
they met by 2030 she wants 100 percent
renewable power sources crammed down by
government let me explain how insane
this is off the top of it okay here is
America's energy
by NRC energy source for 2017 which is
the latest data available 37% of
America's energy consumption came in the
form of petroleum another 29% came in
the form of natural gas another 14% came
in the form of coal another 9% came in
the form of nuclear electric power which
the Democrats don't like 11% of
America's energy supply came from
renewable energy so in other words the
growth of America's economy the growth
of the world economy which is dependent
on the growth of America's economy is
powered 89 percent by sources of energy
that Alexandra Ocasio Cortez doesn't
like she doesn't like nuclear energy so
we're not going to count that even
though that really is a pretty clean
source of energy right France is
basically run on nuclear energy
hey this is it's it's just ridiculous
and by the way even when we talk about
renewable energy okay Wood Wood
constitutes 19 percent of that is not
quite as renewable with people wanting
that has carbon emissions when you use
wood for fuel that actually does have
carbon emissions Solar represents six
percent of the 11 percent that is
renewable energy wind represents 21
percent of the 11 percent in other words
solar and wind represent hydroelectric
represents something like five percent
of the total energy supply of the United
States she wants it to be a hundred
percent by 2030 how is that gonna happen
through massive taxation and quashing of
the American economy that's how it's
going to happen but it doesn't stop
there the document also states that the
green New Deal will advance non
environmental projects such as social
economic racial regional and
gender-based justice what a green New
Deal has to do with gender-based justice
is beyond me oh oh the hell that's even
supposed to mean that matter she says
that we had we should have a national
energy efficient smart grid I'd like her
to design it right since she's obviously
an expert in energy management you know
more so than people in coal and natural
gas and petroleum probably she should
design it right me she's a government
expert she was bartending until five
seconds ago but clearly if there's one
person who knows how to build a national
energy efficient smart grid and that's
not just a mash-up of a bunch of words
that sound nice together it would be
somebody like Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
whose combined brainpower could maybe
maybe provide the electricity to lightly
toast a piece of bread
as long as we're talking about people
providing renewable sources of energy
I'll get some more on Alexander of Kazu
Cortez his idiotic plans all the
Democrats had to do was not be crazy
they couldn't do it and this is the
least crazy part of what they did
yesterday first let's calm down for a
second let's calm down because we're
gonna need to calm down the next two
years gonna be a rocky road and you're
gonna need to calm down what if 2019
instead of being just chaotic was all
about slowing down and being mindful
well we are excited to partner with calm
sea alm the number one app to help you
meditate sleep and relax look at me
do i look like a ball of stress of
course I do but that's why I need cone
right cone is what helps me sleep at
night they have all of these great
aspects of their app that allow you to
relax and meditate and fall asleep
really if you go to comb calm slash Ben
you get twenty five percent off a
compromiso
hundreds of hours of programs including
guided meditation on issues like anxiety
stress and focus there's something
called daily calm which is perfect to
guide you in building of meditation
habit and the best thing is sleep
stories these are bedtime stories for
adults designs help you relax before you
doze off so it's stuff basically it's
people with soothing voices telling you
stories about the lavender fields of
France with Stephen Fry and you are out
like a light man I mean this stuff is
just magic for a limited time then
Shapiro listeners get twenty five
percent off a calm premium subscription
at CA LM comm slash pen that's calm calm
slash man and get unlimited access to
all of comms content today at Combe comm
slash man give yourself the gift of calm
this New Year's it could actually change
your life right sleeping better calming
down make your life so much better calm
calm / man makes it happen for a comb
calm / man when you use that /ban you
get 25% off a comb Premium Subscription
so go check that out right now okay so
back to a OCS grand new deal and again
the reason we're talking about this is
because she is the fresh new face I was
encouraged by a friend of mine on
Twitter who's a professor of policy I
believe it's over at Yale his name is
Howard Forman
he's a health policy and economic policy
adviser you know he he says why don't
you just pay attention why don't you
just pay attention to the more moderates
in the Democratic in the Democratic
caucus because the media is not okay
because the Democrats are not because a
OC is on 60 minutes this Sunday that's
why that's why okay so I'm gonna go
through the rest of her plan and then
we'll tell you how she plans to pay for
all this so she says we should upgrade
every residential and industrial
building for state-of-the-art
energy-efficient comfort and safety as
I'm gonna cost any money we're gonna
retrofit every building in the United
States with all this stuff
eliminating greenhouse gas emissions for
manufacturing agriculture and other
industries how you know how is a good
question how it's a really useful
question how why and these are useful
questions in politics she says funding
massive investments in reducing existing
greenhouse gases but that's not all the
proposed committee would also have
seeming total oversight of American
industry with a mandate for pushing
union membership so it's not just that
we are going to green the economy
through the force of government we are
going to unionize every industry to
green the economy through the force of
government if this sounds a lot like the
government controlling industry from the
top down and destroying the economy
that's because it's precisely what it is
she wants a national jobs force to help
people participate in the transition to
the green economy
she says the green new deal will provide
all members of our society across all
regions in all communities the
opportunity training an education to be
a full and equal participant in the
transition including through a job
guarantee program to assure a living
wage job to every person who wants one
so let me get this straight
we can have the government take over all
the industries and regulate them down to
the ground unionize all the industries
guarantee the employment through all the
industries and redistribute income for
gender-based justice through all of this
have you ever tried anything like this
before in human history yes has it
worked out super well no it turns out
people like their property it turns out
that people are fans of being able to
create people like being entrepreneurs
people like working in creative areas
people like freedom freedom is a nice
thing and but beyond that obviously
that's gonna destroy the economy I mean
it's just immoral for her to suggest
that innovation is dying and therefore
we have to cram it like
what is she ever invented and she mended
a thing I mean granted she like does
Instagram instant pot cooking lessons
but has she ever created like a job I've
never hired anyone you know not with
government money in her congressional
office like an actual job I sure like
produced a product or a good or service
anyone wanted to buy and yet she's gonna
be
the economy perfect perfect also she
says that the plan includes fail-safes
in the form of income Universal income
and medicare for all those there like
the side projects that they're gonna be
working on in their spare time Universal
income and and Medicare for all yeah the
this isn't gonna go wrong in any anyway
so Alexandre Ocasio Cortez puts out this
plan and then she's asked she's on 60
minutes remember she is the new face
she's the new face not my fault you
picked her morons okay so she's the new
face I'm not gonna okay so she and
here's what she says she's asked so how
are you gonna pay for all of this
her answer of course is we are going to
raise taxes massively on the rich here
is her dumb answer again much better at
dancing than economics Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez sometimes you see tax rates as
high as 60 or 70% it doesn't mean all 10
million dollars are taxed at an
extremely high rate but it means that as
you climb up this ladder you should be
contributing more what you are talking
about this big picture is a radical
agenda compared to the way politics is
done right now do you call yourself a
radically yeah you know if that's what
radical means call me a radical okay
well I will you're a radical you're an
insane radical and when she says oh
thank you for explaining marginal tax
rates to me
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez now what would
be awesome is if she explained how much
money the people in the top in the top
quintile of the United States pay in
federal income tax okay here is the
latest statistic this is from April of
2018 okay for 2018 the reality is that
top earners top earners will pay the
overwhelming majority of all taxes in
the United States houses in the top 20%
will have income of about $150,000 or
more and 52% of total income they will
pay 87% of all income taxes 87 percent
of all income taxes are paid for by the
people in the top 20 percent of income
earners but but by the way it's worth
noting here that America has the most
progressive tax system in the entire
industrialized world okay that if you
are and when I say progressive I mean
the more money you make the more money
you pay this is true in America than it
is in any of the European countries that
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is talking about
the reality is that in order to pay for
all of her god off
terrible regulatory economy crushing
programs should have to raise taxes
radically on people who are lower down
on the income scale and when you hear
people like Bernie Sanders say things
like well back in the day of JFK the top
marginal tax rate was 91% why cannot we
do that now a few quick notes about this
idiotic point number one the top
marginal tax rates in the day of
Eisenhower and JFK was indeed 91%
but that was for people who earned
filing jointly 3.4 million dollars in
inflation adjusted dollars the top
marginal tax rate in the United States
today kicks in at about $400,000 it's a
not the same thing - even that
ninety-one percent top marginal tax rate
was never paid for by anyone the
effective tax rate for people making
that amount of money in 1955 was about
45% why because everybody was shielding
their income because of the lower
corporate tax rate and also because
until at that point you're actually
allowed to deduct on your taxes
depreciation on all loans and
depreciation on all real estate so
people just weren't paying that tax rate
is the reality and the economy was good
because people weren't actually paying
that tax rate for every year between
1952 and 2014 the government brought in
between 17 and 20 percent of GDP in tax
revenue and between 7 and 9 percent of
GDP in income tax revenue so just a lie
to suggest the taxes used to be so high
and the economy was awesome when the
tucson's was supa dupa high people just
weren't paying them they just were not
paying them if you really believe that
you can do this too the tax rates and
that magically everything will be ok
you're an idiot and by the way all the
proposals they're talking about these
these medicare-for-all studies guy
benson put this together a few months
ago he talked about how to raise tax
rates to pay for for a OCS and Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all nonsense and
here's what he came up with here's what
you have to do you'd have to raise the
payroll tax paid for by workers and
employers by 10 percentage points for
everyone pay for the workers and the
employer so that's a 20 percent increase
impose a brand-new 20 percent national
VAT sales tax and hike income tax rates
across the board for poor people
middle class people and rich people by
10 percentage points not one of those
all of those all of those this is why if
you look at all the failed so
allistic countries these supposed
socialistic countries that the democrats
like to talk about the Norway's and the
Denmark's the average tax rate across
the board is exorbitant exorbitant
people are paying 60% of their income to
the Denmark e'en government against the
government of Denmark the Danish
government you are paying sixty percent
of your income when you make over sixty
thousand dollars a year in Denmark and
that does not include the national sales
tax which means that when all is said
and done like 80 percent of your income
is going to the government of Denmark
does that sound awesome to you do you
think that might have an impact on you
know how business works in the United
States now it's always easy always
always to look at these Democrat
socialist countries in in northern
Europe and say well look their economies
are still working fine you know why
they're working fine because everyone on
planet earth is reliant on the economic
strength of the United States when the
u.s. hits a depression the rest of the
world hits a depression the economy is
interconnected it's why China right now
is having economic problems and it's
going to affect the US markets if the US
has economic problems everyone goes down
the crapper it's easy to survive with a
population of 6 million and exorbitantly
high tax rates a homogeneous population
of 6 million and exorbitantly high tax
rates you can survive if you've got the
float of the United States bolstering
the world economy all socialism does is
redistribute the gains made by
capitalism but it's slightly a different
thing when there is no back-up plan
what happens when the US economy tanks
because of all these myriad stupidities
being pushed by the radical left in
terms of policy so that's their their
big plan so their big plan is this new
Green Deal big spending Medicare for all
free college for all we're going to do
all of these grandiose things that cost
exorbitant amounts of taxpayer dollars
and are wrongheaded in the extreme as
well you know that when it comes to
their college free-for-all plenty say
well you know we could pay for that by
just raising taxes so a little bit and
we'd pay for the education we don't need
more people going to community colleges
to get degrees they don't need what we
need is more people going into careers
that are useful the idea that college is
inevitably driving income is just wrong
correlation does not equal causation
they're the bottom quintile of college
degree earners is earning less than the
top quintile of high school degree
earners meaning that you can have a high
school degree and still make a good
living in the United States if you're
willing to move up to Montana and work
in oil rigging but apparently we're not
allowed to talk about any of those
things
anymore I guess that wasn't the only
thing on the Democrats agenda this week
so what did they propose in their first
couple of days well we have Brad Sherman
who is my representative here in
California and is a full-fledged doof he
intends to introduce articles of
impeachment against President Trump on
Thursday as the new session of Congress
convenes because this is a priority
we're going to impeach President Trump
with no underlying charges he's going to
accuse Trump of obstruction of justice
in the firing of James Comey which is
absolutely asinine
there's no obstruction of justice in
firing your own FBI director you have
the authority to do that
the Comey himself testified that the
Moller investigation was not hampered in
any way by his firing and yet they're
now gonna try and impeach him but that's
not all they're going to scream about it
so Rasheeda - why've who's another one
of these new faces of fresh face again
I'm not the one labeling these people
the new leaders of the Democratic Party
the Democratic Party are in the media
are not my fault I'm not just
cherry-picking these folks and when
Vanity Fair did their spreadsheet there
their big spread in their new magazine
it's a February issue of power players
in which yours truly appears the
Democrats they chose from Congress were
AOC Rashidah talaiya there's all these
radicals this is the people they chose
to feature this was the new wig the new
diverse magical wing so Rasheeda till I
am is a radical anti-semite and not only
is he in favor of boycott divestment and
sanctions from the State of Israel
she has tweeted out radically awful
things about Israel and Jews before
she's a terrible person
Andra shoot Italia but we can't say that
she's a terrible person because she's
diverse right she's one of the first
Muslim American Congress people she
along with another one of her colleagues
in Congress this year she is she is just
they are their Muslim and this means
that they're inherently good right this
means they're inherently good because
diversity is inherently good Rasheed at
Eliab number one her office in media I
mean just to show who she is she moves
into her congressional office and Hanna
alum who is a reporter tweets out this
photo of a map in her office and says
someone has already made a slight
alteration to the map that hangs and
receded to lie of sneaking rational
office what does it show
it shows a post-it note that has been
placed over Egypt with an arrow toward
Israel and the word
she wants to replace Israel with
Palestine which means the genocide of
the Jews in the area and she has placed
that on her map in her congressional
office but don't worry she's new and
fresh faced also we know she's new and
fresh because she uses lots of curse
words
now I remember a time you know 30
seconds ago when we kept hearing that
Donald Trump was a very vulgar bad man
because he's vulgar and bad now there
are those of us who don't like vulgarity
there are those of us who think that
Donald Trump is vulgar and that his
vulgarity is not excusable and that it's
a bad thing there are those of us who
think that this sort of approach to
politics is ugly whether it's
Republicans or Democrats but there's
something a little hypocritical about
the Democrats whining about vulgarity
and then celebrating is Rashidah to lie
about there and says that her chief goal
is going to be impeaching the mother
effer
issues caught saying this yesterday on
tape here she was bullies don't win baby
because we're gonna go in there we're in
impeach the mother that's how you know
she's offensive and by the way if she's
head towards water impeach for the
mother effer that's not very good
parenting I mean I don't know her - how
old her daughter is but I don't curse to
my children that's that's a bizarre
choice now that doesn't mean that people
can say like if you're not pissed at
Trump doing the sort of stuff then
you're not allowed to really be pissed
at Rasheeda til I am for doing this sort
of stuff but the same holds true the
other way so Nancy Pelosi who's been
whining about Donald Trump being vulgar
for the last several years at this point
she shied away from moving forward with
impeachment but she said that the
language used by Rasheeda - why've well
it was no worse than what he said she
said that impeachment is divisive but
she's not actually gonna like chide
Rasheeda - I overheard on radicals this
is gonna be an ongoing problem for Nancy
Pelosi here was Pelosi basically making
room for her own radicals while at the
same time pretending that only the
Republicans are radicals many Democrats
are talking about impeachment
you've said it would be sad and divisive
for the country we pursue impeachment
are you willing to rule it out well we
have to wait and see what happens with
the Moller
report we shouldn't be impeaching for a
political reason
and we shouldn't avoid impeachment for a
political reason so we just have to see
how it comes so that's her saying
impeachment is on the table she can't
really name what I get but sure why not
and then she says about the the language
used she says generationally that would
not be language I would use but
nonetheless I don't think we should make
a big deal of it the hypocrisy of
politicians is so tiring it's so tiring
okay if you're going to complain about
Donald Trump's behavior then when your
own members use that same kind of
behavior you have to condemn it and the
same holds true on the right if you're
gonna condemn Rashidah its Eliab then
when President Trump uses this kind of
behavior you should also condemn it okay
you need to be consistent with these
sorts of standards otherwise there are
no standards at all with which to be
consistent but that wasn't the only
thing that Democrats were doing
yesterday we shoot until I have bat fur
for her part she tweeted out that she's
unapologetic about using the mother F
for shiz I will always speak truth to
power
hashtag unapologetically me uh I'm so
tired
it's January 4th and I'm so tired it
will always speak truth to power yeah
speaking truth to power is calling the
president and a mother effer as people
cheer wildly for you wow what a
difficult life you lead Rasheeda till I
am who being elected once and and then
saying whatever you want in people
cheering for you because you're a
diverse Congress person and I love it
when it's like unapologetically me I'm
here and I'm proud to be me you're so
boring you know it's not boring
self-betterment
you know what actually is boring I'm me
oh it's so just self-absorbed
congratulations you know who else is me
my son me poops in his diaper just
ridiculous okay that's not the only
thing Democrats we're doing either also
representative Steve Cohen introduced
two bills on Thursday one to eliminate
the electoral college so that's exciting
it's particularly exciting because he
doesn't understand how the Constitution
works you can't introduce a bill to will
remove the electoral college it's part
of the Constitution you you
actually have to introduce a
constitutional amendment which would
never pass so glad to see the Democrats
have all their priorities in the correct
place Hank Johnson a man who thinks that
the island of Guam is going to tip over
from too many people because he's a
highly intelligent human this is
congressman Hank Johnson from the GA
fourth District meanwhile he is ranting
and raving about how Trump supporters
are all committing suicide so Democrats
really demonstrating that they should be
sit with power now for their whole pitch
was you can't trust Trump with power and
now their whole pitch is we crazy I mean
so here here's here's Hank Johnson being
totally nuts Donald Trump supporters are
older less educated less prosperous and
they are dying early their lifespans are
decreasing and many are dying from
alcoholism drug overdoses liver disease
or simply a broken heart caused by
economic despair yeah that's what from
supporters are they're all dying
committing suicide it's all different
supporters that's that's what's
happening here
no Democrats have ever committed heroin
overdoses none I mean incredible
incredible knowledge being dropped there
by Hank Johnson who legitimately said
that an island was going to tip over
because of overpopulation oh yeah yeah
the good news though is that the media
are doing yeoman's work in covering the
Democrats CNN took Nancy Pelosi for ice
cream I am not kidding you remember when
they did this appalling Ryan when he
became Speaker no I neither do I
remember when Donald Trump became
president and they took him for a
milkshake we know he likes milkshakes
Bill O'Reilly took him from milkshake
ones okay but do you remember when CNN
did that I don't but here they are
taking charming Nancy Pelosi over to the
local Vaqueros for some ice cream
hopefully sugar-free so it doesn't melt
wait those dentures here they are on CNN
she attributes her boundless energy to
Italian jeans it's certainly not a
balanced diet dark chocolate and ice
cream the carros has been her favorite
since she was a little girl not -
chocolate chip - chocolate I like my
chocolate unadulterated okay so that's a
thing she likes her chocolate
unadulterated good coverage there CNN
solid coverage I mean I can't imagine
why people think CNN to bias Network
come on that's not bias that's
hard-hitting reporting she attributes
her long-standing life expectancy to
Italian genes very very important stuff
by the way do we have any data about
like whether Italians live longer I
don't know that that data exists but no
matter she is she's an old lady and we
have to we have to trust
she loves dark chocolate and she loves
ice cream and she used to go to Vaqueros
as a child and this means that she is
going to legislate on behalf of the
children Oh
CNN you suck so radically much yeah it
makes you actually want to chant that in
like a rally I really like CNN sucks I
mean that that just just awful stuff
okay so I want to get to the government
shutdown which continues I also want to
get to the markets which have been all
over the place and a very good economic
report for president Raman we'll do some
mail back to you so a lot coming up
you're gonna have to go over to Daily
wire calm right now and subscribe when
you do that for $9.99 a month you got
the rest of the show live you get the
rest of the show on video coming up on
Monday you get two additional hours per
day of the Ben Shapiro show it's gonna
be unbelievable you're gonna love it
you're gonna live it it's gonna be your
life experience you get that starting on
Monday because our radio show our
two-hour live radio show and the
afternoons that's a thing that's
happening and you're only gonna be able
to listen to the the back episodes of
that and listen to it at all if you are
a subscriber unless you listened to it
on live radio on our syndicated show so
that's pretty amazing I mean we're
working our fingers to the bone for you
as subscribers plus when you spend $99 a
year you get this you left us cheers hot
or cold tumblr is cheaper than $9.99 a
month and you get this I mean look at
this thing I'm beginning to feel
healthier each day I feel a little bit
better and that's because I like to sip
in moderation from this were I to
actually just gulp from the leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr I would
immediately become immortal but if I
were immoral I could no longer speak to
mere mortals and then my show would end
so instead I sip from it I become a
little healthier every day
the leftist chairs hot or cold tumblr
keeps hot things hot cold things cold
how does it know unbelievable you can go
check that out for $99 a year also
please subscribe at YouTube or iTunes we
have a great Sunday special this week
with General Stanley McChrystal which is
really fascinating stuff some really
good episodes coming up in the very near
future so many goodies coming just for
you subscribe youtube itunes all the
rest of it leave us a review that always
helps us we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so the the government
shutdown meanwhile continues apace as
the Democrats push out their own idiotic
policies they say one thing that they
will certainly certainly not pay for so
we'll spend literally trillions of
dollars on programs that do not work
Medicare for all they're gonna spend
trillions of dollars on universal basic
income they're gonna spend trillions of
dollars on a green new deal which is
just basically a cronies bundle where
they pay their friends and their union
cronies they're gonna spend billions of
dollars and they will not give president
from five point six billion dollars for
a wall No Deal no no not a dime and
Nancy Pelosi is saying that she says I
will offer a president Trump one dollar
she literally said this hey her opening
bargaining position was like Alec
Baldwin from 30 rock
one dollar here she is situation which
you would accept even a dollar of wall
[Music]
she's in such a good mood she's been a
dollar you know as the there's an old
Oscar Wilde joke in which Oscar Wilde
apparently went up to a woman at a
cocktail party and he said to her you
know would you this hanging that's
powerful cuz Oscar Wilde was gay but in
any case what asked her Wilde went up to
supposedly went up to this woman and he
said to her madam would you would you
sleep with me for a million pounds and
she said I'd have to think about it they
said well you sleep would you sleep with
me for one pound and she said how dare
you sir what kind of woman do you think
I is well we already know what you are
we're just haggling over the price now
really I mean if Nancy Pelosi is willing
to give $1 why not five point six
billion I mean really same thing in
federal government terms in any case
they will not grant a dollar for the
wall or if they will it's like one
dollar and then she said meanwhile Mike
Pence says the shutdown is gonna
continue without the wall which by the
way it should we'll talk about the
politics of this in just a second
because there are a lot of people saying
law it's going to damage president Trump
Democrats are in control of Congress now
I'm not sure that's how this is gonna
play out
ever since the Christmas holiday the
president sent us to Capitol Hill I met
with Senator Schumer not once but twice
we engaged in good-faith negotiations
the president I cancelled all of our
Christmas vacation plans we were here in
Washington DC Democrats broke off
negotiations about a week ago but the
president's made it clear we're here to
make a deal but it's a deal that's gonna
result in achieving real gains on border
security and you have no border security
without a wall we will have no deal
without a wall by the way Penn's
apparently in a meeting already once a
Schumer and said we don't need 5.6
billion will do 2.5 billion and then
Schumer was like well you guys said you
wanted 5.6 billion in Trump sat there
nodding at Schumer it's just amazing
undercutting pence in the room during
the negotiations is just incredible
stuff but the fact is that the Trump
administration is willing to move the
Democrats are simply not willing to move
President Trump called sort of an
impromptu press conference he went into
the press room yesterday he
congratulated Nancy Pelosi and then he
talked about the border wall and he is
correct to do so I just want to start
off by congratulating Nancy Pelosi on
being elected Speaker of the House it's
a very very great achievement and
hopefully we're going to work together
and we're gonna get lots of things done
like infrastructure and so much more I
know they want to do that very badly so
do I so hopefully we're gonna have a lot
of things that we can get done together
and I think it's actually gonna work out
I think it'll be a little bit different
than a lot of people are thinking so I
congratulate Nancy tremendous tremendous
achievement okay and then he went on and
talked about you know why we needed a
wall and he is right about that so this
is trumping an arrest the media a crack
down on him anyway how dare presidents
from interrupt the swearing-in of these
new democratic members how dare he steal
the spotlight because Obama never stole
the spotlight from anybody that was
never his thing
Obama he was just issued the spotlight
like crazy if there's one thing I
remember about Barack Obama that was a
man who disdained the spotlight he
definitely never wanted to be the center
of attention President Trump did put out
a tweet about the border wall it was it
was basically about the crisis on the
border showing video of people climbing
the border even show it all narrate it
he's he's it's video showing people
throwing rocks at border agents and
criminals throwing rocks border agents
drugs being shipped over the border and
all the rest and him saying we need a
border wall all of this is obvious he
had a bunch of border agents to the
White House and in typical media fashion
it demonstrates exactly where the
media's heads are apt so he had at this
presser a bunch of border agents who
came forward and they blasted the
Democrats over
well here's what they had to say I've
been a virtual agent for 21 years I can
personally tell you from the work that I
have done on the southwest border that
physical barriers that walls actually
work you all got to ask yourself this
question if I come to your home do you
want me to knock on the front door or do
you want me to climb through that window
these criminal aliens that have been
released from jail that have been
deported will come right back into the
United States however we had a physical
barrier if we had a wall we will be able
to stop that okay so you don't Trump
said this and the border agents say it
and they're all right I mean this is all
exactly correct but the media don't
cover that the media instead cover it as
though there's an open debate to be had
about this the Democrats have not put
forward a single proposal for how they
plan to stop illegal immigration to
border not one not a proposal and yet
the pressure is supposed to be on
President Trump
President Trump should bring these
border agents with him everywhere he
should go on a national tour with these
border agents he should go down to the
border right now to the empty area of
the border there is no wall here do you
think that our border agents are magic
you think they can just stop people
walking over the border we have no way
of alerting them to people crossing
these borders Trump should make this a
national issue and he should force Nancy
Pelosi to answer why she's willing to
allow government workers to be
furloughed simply to not pay for a wall
they're gonna have to explain that one
so Trump is not wrong through this
meanwhile the markets have been tumbling
they been going up and down and all
around but there's a very good economic
report that came out today the new
economic report shows an amazing 312
thousand jobs added in December plus
average hourly pay improved 3.2 percent
from a year ago up from an average wage
growth of 2.7 percent at the end of 2017
it's a very very solid economic report
the amount that was expected was like
200,000 jobs had it it's three hundred
twelve thousand jobs added instead the
unemployment unemployment rate did rise
slightly to three point nine percent
because people were looking for more
work they've gotten back into the jobs
market four percent is basically
considered by economists full employment
to have a full employment economy and
Democrats are treating it as though we
are supposed to wrecked that economy
with 70 percent tax rates across the
board and massive green scams designed
to pay off all of their political
cronies Trump should just run on their
radicalism right this would be a very
good now Trump has an opponent so is
suggested yesterday by the execrable
michael knowles that the that president
from does better when he has an opponent
natural opponent now he has actual
opponents in Congress maybe that's true
he should aim his fire directly at their
idiotic programs that hey they are
pushing as hard as they possibly can
because they're gonna keep pushing these
programs even if the economy is good now
there are warning signs on the horizon
for the economy Apple for example
announced that its earnings would come
up short
that's because Apple has been poorly run
I mean really the products just are not
as innovative as they once were and this
is one of the realities of the economy
it's why when people talk about Google
being inevitably large and eating the
world economy and all the rest of it
companies rise companies fall the number
of companies that have been on the S&P
500 is not 500 over the course of the
last 50 years in a several thousand
because companies join companies fall
off there was a time when Apple was a
secondary company when IBM was the big
company and now IBM is barely alive and
Apple is on top well Apple will fall to
the same will happen with Google I
remember a time when Alta Vista was the
thing and Yahoo was the thing okay all
these companies rise and fall because of
innovation
now innovation makes people
uncomfortable it makes them feel like
they're not in control there are a lot
of articles today out in the New York
Times about how innovation is basically
stalling and we don't know where the
next big thing is gonna come from if we
knew where the next big thing was gonna
come from then I would have invested in
it wouldn't of you I mean the innovation
always takes us by surprise as well as
should in a free economy innovation
always takes us by surprise which is why
we should remove all barriers to
innovation and that means we should
reduce tax rates we should reduce
regulations we should reduce tariffs
innovation entrepreneurship people
coming up with new and better stuff that
is what creates a booming economy and
will create the next wave of stuff and
we don't have to know where that's
coming from the great lie that's told by
centralized planners is that there are a
few geniuses who can just forecast where
technology is going to go again if they
could forecast where technology we're
going to go
they would just invest in the technology
and be rich themselves certainly the
folks at government level can't do that
when you try to force innovation
it generally fails it does not succeed
innovation can only happen when people
are left to their own free devices the
inspiration of man has allowed 7.3
billion people to remain alive on a
planet that really in in a subsistence
economy would sustain maybe a billion
it's just not it's not credible to
believe the technology is not gonna
continue to advance in the wake of human
ingenuity and human intelligence that
seems to be the case made by folks on
the left is that human intelligence and
ingenuity suddenly they're not up to the
task
capitalism which has raised nearly the
entire globe from abject poverty needs
to be curbed because it's too rapacious
and greedy and terrible and all the rest
and this sort of stuff is just it's
foolish it's it's foolish but
foolishness is stock and trade for a lot
of folks these days and that's what
President Trump should campaign on
because it turns out that whatever
president Trump's problems at least he
isn't proposing destroying the entire
United States and thus world economy on
the shoulders of centralized planning by
bartenders from New York ok let's get
into the mailbag for a few minutes so
Annette says hey my seven-year-old is
super into US history he really enjoys
watching crass crash course on US
history videos however I've noticed a
significant liberal bent in a lot of
these videos you have any
recommendations for US history that are
trustworthy and could still be
considered somewhat entertaining to a
seven-year-old well you know I've
recommended for years the musical 1776
my daughter is four she loves the
musical 1776 because indeed it is in
fact musical I've been seriously
considering the possibility of putting
out podcasts on American history we're
putting out graphic novels on American
history because I think that it is ill
taught and I think the most entertaining
versions are put together by folks from
Hollywood who legitimately are
attempting to bias American history in
the worst possible way but listen there
is sophistication to American history
there are nuances to American history
not all of American history is glorious
and wonderful but the overarching thrust
of American history and philosophy is
inherently wonderful and if that's not
what kids are initially taught and there
instead taught that America was
initially bad and was founded on racism
and sexism and slavery and all this kind
of stuff then what they're gonna come
away with is a leftist version of
history that ignores the transformative
power of the United States and really
doesn't answer the question as to why
the u.s. is so good so powerful and so
righteous on the world stage across the
scope of history Daniel says hey bud is
the extra two-hour thing already
happening where can I go to tune in well
it begins on Monday so you can go to
your local radio station we may be
carrying it we are going to be on in all
the major markets in real time it
broadcasts live from
12 to 3 on the west coast right so it'll
be the first hour is the recut version
of the podcast and then the last two
hours are going to be live radio but it
plays is basically a three hour radio
show so you should be able to find that
at your local at your local radio
station if you don't catch it there then
you need to subscribe you need to go
over to daily we're calm and subscribe
and then you can actually join me during
the breaks like one of the things we're
planning is that occasionally during
breaks I'll take questions from you in
the audience and we'll have fun with our
subscribers so go check that out of
daily wire comm Mathis says hey I'm a
new subscriber after a year of watching
on YouTube I'm a follower of the
intellectual dark web and have been
intrigued and disturbed by the recent
developments with patreon banning of
sargon of akkad
I've been following Dave Reubens and
Jordan Peterson's recent announcement to
leave patreon with the hope to create a
competitor platform what are your
thoughts on the Reuben Peterson platform
and on Peterson's worried about the
change of terms site movement and
potential for credit card companies to
further the social push toward radical
leftist ideologies and censorship on the
Internet
well my view is that Jordan and and Dave
are doing exactly the right thing and
not only that there's all sorts of
market opportunities that are going to
be opened up by the censorship of the
left if MasterCard decides that they're
going to crack down on your ability to
subscribe to my show for example people
will just get another credit card and
that's all that will happen
freedom finds a way and then if Jeff
Goldblum said that life finds a way so
does freedom so does Liberty if people
can somehow find a way to listen to this
show in China and I know there are
people who do then you can certainly
find a way to get another credit card to
listen to the show if these credit card
companies decide to try and reach out
and harm you Veronica says we had a
discussion in the DW chat that sparked
this question since alcohol kills more
people here than drugs doesn't make
sense to legalize marijuana cocaine etc
and ban alcohol in my view when it comes
to all of these things is that
legalization is is preferable for all
substances and that it is your personal
responsibility not to abuse the
substances we have ancillary crimes that
are attached to abuse of those
substances it's if you smoke pot and and
then you go and commit and then you
drive while smoking pot that's a crime
Ren's DUI if you become violence after
using cocaine then that is a crime but
the real question about legalization of
drugs is whether there are certain drugs
that are so powerful that they actually
robbed you of your capacity to reason
and be a good citizen in the process and
there aren't
drugs that do make you into a zombie I
mean heroin obviously makes you into a
zombie so would legalization of heroin
now then the question becomes is
government policy and criminalization
effective in combating the use of heroin
or not and I think the evidence on that
is fairly mixed I believe that heroin is
actually legal in in places like
Amsterdam and I'm not sure that it has
radically increased the number of people
who are addicted to heroin for example
and wanted to do some more research on
that topic drew says hey Ben I've heard
you say a few a few times you're an
absolutist when it comes to free speech
in the First Amendment therefore I'm
curious what your thoughts were on free
speech in schools specifically high
school the two Scouts cases I immediate
SCOTUS cases I immediately think of our
Tinker versus Des Moines Independence's
School District and Morse versus
Frederick do you think students give up
some of these rights when they attend a
public or a private school do you think
these rights should be preserved and
respected at these schools thanks for
all you do for the conservative
community well you do give up certain
rights depending on their time place and
manner restrictions it's not appropriate
for you to get up and protest in the
middle of your math class because
there's actual jobs that have to be
taken care of in that math class such as
teaching math for example I'm not sure
that free speech applies in the same way
in in public schools so long as it is
not impeding the educational mission of
the school I think free speech is fine
if it is impeding the educational
mission of the school then I think that
obviously free speech is a problem but
that's not the same thing as bringing in
a guest speaker on college campus for
example or restricting certain types of
political activity at the expense of
other types of political activity I mean
the general rule when it comes to time
place and manner restrictions is that
they have to be content-neutral Isaac
says hey Ben your argument against Trump
pulling our military presence from the
Middle East is solid allow me to present
a counter-argument made you may not have
heard in short we need our troops here
at home we've lost all our important
social fabric to the ravages of
tribalism and nihilism we're now
embroiled in a culture war against these
forces may be the return home of a bunch
of people who believe in this country
and have an interest in restoring our
social fabric is just what we need to
win set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world well
honestly listen I think that our troops
are unbelievable people I mean they're
they're incredible they're far braver
than I they they made a commitment that
I have not made I have nothing but
praise for them the idea that you joined
the military to be at home and then
influence other people I don't think is
exactly correct I mean what you're
actually suggesting more effectively
be some sort of national service program
like Israel but everybody does a year of
national service everybody serves in the
army
I'm generally uncomfortable with
government force being used that way I
think rebuilding of the social fabric
ground up through local community is a
better solution Matthew says Ben I'm
looking at becoming a political
commentator hopefully similar to what
you do what college degrees and courses
would you suggest to be the best
equipped for this path I mean I'm not
sure the college prepares you to
actually do any of this stuff I think
that that taking Poli Sci courses then
reading all the stuff they don't want
you to read is probably useful and I
think they're taking a journalism course
and realizing what it is that they want
you to do is is maybe a little useful
learning how to write in an English
course is useful but mostly I actually
believe this about college generally
unless you are going to a college that
is pushing you to learn a skill set that
is specific so my wife was in pre-med
and now she's a doctor right I know I
know shocking but that's an actual
college degree that's worth something
I'm not sure that it's necessarily worth
something to go to college and then
major in a subject where you're actually
gonna learn what to do while you're on
the job as far as being a political
commentator or opinion maker I always
say to young people the first thing
people want is information people like
our show because we're information first
we provide you enormous amounts of
information and then my opinion and this
is true when you are in college as well
you have access to information stuff
that's happening on your campus as
Andrew Breitbart said to everyone to me
also
he said listen if you have a cell phone
you are now a reporter and this is true
you can see something bad happened on
your campus you have access to
information you should distribute that
information it'll make you more worth
listening to
okay let's see just says you're been in
downtown Portland homeless people
wandering around with trash bags full of
cans which they collect to turn in for
money are ubiquitous as I walked to put
some cans in my buildings recycling bins
today I wondered he's leaving cans and
recycling bins the new leaving a corner
of one's wheat field for the poor if not
what is thanks from a former Jewish day
school student so that's a reference to
pea and Luckett which are which are
biblical sort of taxes now you're
supposed to leave one basically you're
supposed to leave a corner of your field
unreached for the poor and if you go
through your field and you drop stuff on
the ground you're not supposed to pick
it up you're supposed to leave that for
the poor as well is that what recycling
is it kind of a funny idea I don't think
so I think that the idea of pan like it
was to provide
job opportunities for people that they
were it wasn't you were supposed to pick
the the grain and then hand it over to a
poor person although that is a form of
tadaka of charity you were sexually
supposed to leave something for the poor
people to do so that they become
self-sufficient and I think that that's
what we should be aiming toward giving
people the job is the highest form of
charity okay let's see maybe one more
question let's do this one okay
Joshua says my issue has to do with the
United States not producing enough
children to sustain a growing population
because we aren't having enough kids it
will impact the economy Social Security
etc but having paid maternity leave like
Europe be enough of an incentive for
parents to have more kids
no the answer is no paid maternity leave
is not the reason people aren't having
kids and if that were true then Europe
would be having a lot of kids they're
not having a lot of kids it is a
cultural thing to have a lot of kids in
the Orthodox Jewish community the
average number of children is four plus
in the Catholic community the average
number of children is similar it's three
four people okay the the average number
of kids being had in second where
households is under two and the reason
for that is because kids are a pain in
the butt okay look really just putting
this as blatantly as possible
kids are a giant pain in the butt
they're also the most wonderful thing
that will ever happen to you in your
life don't get me wrong but there are a
lot of hassle they change your life
radically you have to plan every day
around most minut needs of your children
have to change your schedules to deal
with them you have to deal with their
fussing and their whining you have to
feed them right they are there a large
time and energy drain well it used to be
that the reason people had kids was so
that they could work the farm or so one
day when you were old your kids would
take care of you but in the era when the
government is supposedly going to take
care of you which it won't but in an era
when the government is supposed to take
care of you then the idea is that you
don't actually need kids to do all of
that stuff the only reason to have kids
would be to pay for these programs 20
years down the road but you're gonna be
dead so what do you care so people
aren't having kids kids have become a
net negative as opposed to a net asset
well that means that people are not
going to have kids which means the only
reason people are having kids really is
for religious reasons because they
believe that it's a good thing for the
world to have kids because they believe
that kids aren't inherent good and
because there still is a human
biological need and this is particularly
true one woman to have children it
doesn't mean that every woman wants to
have children the vast vast majority of
women are happier having kids they are
and and all this talk about how your
be fulfilled having a career as a
high-powered lawyer at 50 with no kids
is nonsense
it's just not the case you may be
fulfilled if that's part of your life
but if that's your whole life there's
not a man or woman who's totally
fulfilled by that but particularly not a
woman who feels that she forewent her
magical power of being able to produce
it and spawn another human being and did
that so they could build more hours of
the office I just don't think that's a
recipe for happiness and feminism which
has taught women this has made more
women miserable so I think that the cure
for this is a values cure it's
non-economic here I don't think it's
about paid maternity leave now is there
a conservative argument for paid
maternity leave yeah I think there is
which is why I think that there are a
lot of private companies that undertake
that argument but I think it's
ridiculous to suggest that for example
my private company has to pay people for
taking time off should be forced by the
government to pay people for taking time
off at the same rate they would be if
they were working like that's something
I want to offer to incentivize really
well qualified women to come to the
company because that's something I
believe in great but if the idea is I'm
supposed to sacrifice the economic
income of the company because you are
making a personal choice to have a child
that's top-down control I'm very much
opposed to it okay time for a couple of
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like so the over
over the last couple of days driving
right with the kids and I realized my
kids were not familiar what the work of
Stevie Wonder Stevie Wonder is one of
the most talented musicians of the 20th
and 21st centuries and I think is it
safe to say sort of underrated because
people say that Michael Jackson is the
King of Pop so I was listening to some
Michael Jackson I'm not sure there's a
Michael Jackson album you'd actually
want to listen to beginning to end like
three times Stevie Wonder's stuff is
fan-freaking-tastic man is just
unbelievably talented and obviously his
best song is superstition the bassline
of which is the catchiest bassline in
the history of pop music there's a
little bit of superstition for folks not
familiar if you've been living under a
rock with the work of Stevie Wonder
really I do think underrated I tweeted
out Stevie Wonder over Michael Jackson I
got a lot of flack for it I was kind of
shocked by that I thought this is
perfectly obvious Stevie Wonder is a
much better musician than than Michael
Jackson and it just again I may have my
political disagreements with Stevie
Wonder but talent man I mean he's he's
incredible he he he works in a variety
of genres
he's terrific here here's a little bit
of Stevie Wonder
[Music]
I mean the man can sing man can play
multiple instruments mean he's really a
talented guy so don't forget about the
Stevie Wonder Stevie Wonder Stan tastic
and by the way he would have survived in
my box okay so a couple of things that I
hate today so demonstrating once again
that our social media outrage culture
absolutely stinks this is a story from
the Daily Caller at first
it appeared to be just another story
about a white person calling the cops on
a black person over the summer a
supposedly racially motivated phone call
to the police that caught international
attention out of hundreds of others
stories of police arriving scenes around
the United States to find black people
committing crimes of barbecuing sleeping
in the university dorm common room or
selling water bottles we're taking over
the media with each story a white person
made the phone call and each caller was
given a memorable nickname in this case
the caller was doorway Debbie I don't
remember this one on a midsummer day in
July Darcelle Obregon ducked into an
apartment building to shelter herself
from the rain while waiting for an uber
minutes later the front door swung open
and out walked a 19 year old girl who
demanded that Obregon leave the premises
immediately the residents name is
airball Torres a 19 year old student at
Brooklyn College who also has autism I
came downstairs and a woman was standing
as I am right now and wouldn't leave
said Torres what might have been an
unremarkable high-strung incident that
occurs hundreds of times a day New York
City ended up becoming a fake news story
that raised baited an incident without
any credible evidence of bigotry Torres
said hey ma'am this is private property
could you please move okay and the the
woman the Obregon is an assistant to a
fashion model
she flat-out refused to leave after
about 10 times of me saying ma'am go
this is private property Obregon still
refused so I called the cops as a person
with autism I was scared when somebody
is blocking me from leaving it's a
problem and I was alone in that
situation sort of style 9-1-1 so Obregon
whipped out her phone and began filming
later that evening the words worthless
skank popped up on her phone when Torres
was at a Broadway show messages porn in
hashtags like white privilege and
barbecue Becky were included obregón
Facebook post reads on Sunday afternoon
I was in Brooklyn walking to the train
when a sudden rainstorm began I hid in
the doorway outside of a random
apartment to shield myself from rain no
more than three minutes later a young
woman who lives in the building open the
front door and told me I cannot stand
there and had to leave and then she
proceeded it's called the police and
then she released all of this tape and
there's there's a lot of talk about how
she was maybe hi or maybe she's not
Spanish
she looks Jewish right all this stuff
it turns out that this woman is was
diagnosed with autism
she has ASD and Torres said that for an
individual with autism she's pretty good
at communication but when she sees her
here's people outside the building it
triggers feelings of paranoia and
tremendous discomfort doesn't matter she
was labeled too racist and this story
was reported at Ebenezer
and at the New York Post and all the
rest it turns out the Taurus herself is
not white and she's not even sure that
Obregon is black so well done social
media makes everybody feel better to
tweet about how people are terrible
without actually recognizing maybe
you're the terrible one for jumping to a
conclusion in the first place so well
done there New York City also another
another crazy story today New York City
added to the growing list of US states
and cities to offer residents a third
gender option on their birth
certificates now here is why this is
absolutely asinine okay when you are
born you have a sex the purpose of
putting a sex on your birth certificate
is so that if a doctor let's say that
something happens there's a car crash
and the baby has to be rushed to the
hospital and now you have to determine
what how to operate on the baby or the
child and you actually have to determine
how are you going to credibly deal with
this child health problems are different
based on sex for example let's say that
you are in a situation where where you
have a government Census being done to
determine how health care is is
differentiating between males and
females and can health care be changed
to change any sort of imbalance then
these statistics matter the purpose for
the government keeping statistics is so
that we can use them for our for our
data production for purposes of public
policy mixing that up by putting X on a
birth certificate is just absolutely
idiot
it's idiocy it's just idiocy the new law
allows the choice of X in addition to
male or female the non-binary category
can be selected by those who identify as
non-binary as well as my parents who
choose the category for newborn children
now what's so amazing about this part
you know the parents who choose the
category for newborn children first of
all you don't get to choose your own sex
that's nonsense you're you are a
biological human and second I love the
idea that I am imposing on my child by
recognizing a biological reality but I
am not imposing on my child by
pretending biological reality doesn't
exist so it is not an agenda driven item
for me to suggest that my child is
neither male nor female but it is an
agenda driven item for me to recognize
that my boy
has a penis all of this is insane it's
fully insane New York Mayor Bill
DeBlasio dropped the groundhog and then
praised the law for furthering the
city's commitment to defending the
rights of the LGBTQ community he
reiterated his stance in a statement
this week he said transgender and gender
non-conforming New Yorkers deserve the
right to choose how they identify and to
live with respect and dignity you do not
get to choose how people identify you
you can choose how you identify change
your name call yourself
Bojangles call yourself whatever you
want doesn't matter okay they call it
like just call yourself a cat I don't
care but if you insist that society
treat you as a non-biological entity
then you are living in a world of
fantasy and that's just reality that
there's just nonsense California already
does this so does Washington and Oregon
now I always laugh at this sort of stuff
because the truth is that in the end
none of this is going to matter at all
biology outweighs all of this stuff and
that this will be a fringe phenomenon a
few people will do it it'll become
trendy for a while and then it'll go
away because no one is going to actually
do this overall but the fact that we are
all supposed to change what biology is
so that your self-identification becomes
how we use objective measures to
identify you so basically the government
the government defines you so you define
yourself to the government and then the
government defines you for everyone else
and that is a form of thought control
that I just simply am NOT going to
engage in alright so we'll be back here
next week and I'm sure there will be
much more news and when we are back here
on Monday it'll be two additional live
hours of the bench peer show so
subscribe now because you want to be
part of it otherwise you're not to be
able to hear unless you're listening to
live radio in a major market it's the
afternoon you're driving home you missed
the show you get to listen to when you
go to Dealey where DICOM so go subscribe
right now now there's never been a
better time we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
Ford publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018